[Music]
here's your money briefing for Wednesday
April 26th I'm Danny Lewis for the Wall
Street Journal filling in for J.R Whalen
her concert season is just around the
corner and if you're looking to see an
A-list music act like Taylor Swift
Beyonce or Bruce Springsteen get your
wallet ready
in the last few years the face value for
concert tickets has risen over a hundred
dollars on average and on the resale
Market those same seats can go for
anywhere from 250 to over a thousand
dollars depending on the artist Rachel
wolf from the wsj life and work team
joins us to explain how concert tickets
became such a splurge
Rachel why are they so expensive now
so there are a few different things
going on Experts point to unprecedented
levels of demand driving up the base
price but also the fact that there are
now a lot of added fees and other costs
associated with tickets that weren't
there before so if you're a big Swifty
or part of the Beehive or the BTS Army
and you aren't usually able to just toss
off hundreds of dollars for a ticket
what do you do some people I spoke to
are getting second jobs just to afford a
concert ticket but really I was speaking
to Consumers who are scrimping elsewhere
in order to splurge to see their
favorite artists because those who
aren't able to get tickets during an
initial drop are forced to rely on
resale and those tickets are shooting up
as well inflation has meant that
consumers dollars don't go as far as
they used to why are people still
willing to spend so much money on a
single show so the people that I spoke
to said that after not being able to go
to concerts during the panda and just
with everything now being so expensive
they want to decide how they're
splurging so they think that it's a
valuable experience groceries are going
to be so expensive and going to the
movies is going to be so expensive they
aren't surprised that going to see a
concert is now so expensive but they
would rather go see a concert than go
out to eat yeah it's kind of that split
brain decision making kind of thing
right exactly so how are some fans
changing their lives and spending habits
in order to afford some of these tickets
so a bunch of the people I spoke to are
really cutting back elsewhere in order
to afford to go these aren't people who
are necessarily going into debt to go
see Taylor Swift they're just
prioritizing that Splurge over basically
anything else for the month especially
people who don't have kids and who can
sort of afford to pay it they're just
going without elsewhere and as I
mentioned one person I spoke to has
actually been door dashing and doing
other sorts of food delivery is just to
afford her BTS habit yeah that's a
pretty big jump to me to be able to
afford to go to a show what's the effect
of all this on the performers are any of
them changing the way they do shows or
sell merch as a result of these big
ticket prices so the price of
merchandise for talking t-shirts Koozies
magnets have all gone up and the music
managers I spoke to told me that it's
because the cost for performers have
gone up as well so their hotels their
travel hiring personnel has gotten a lot
more expensive and then the actual cost
to produce the merchandise have gone up
so that's being passed on to the fans
who you know if they're going to the
show many of them can't leave without
the T-shirt but that is a lot more
expensive than it used to be too and
this is all happening while the concert
industry is still catching up after the
first few years of the pandemic when
there weren't really a lot of shows
happening if any what happens if the
prices get high enough to make demand
weighing you know I think that's a
concern that music managers said they
have especially with the fears of a
recession that people scripting
elsewhere won't be enough to afford the
concert you know if they're just trying
so hard to get by so that's definitely
something that artists are Reckoning
with right now is this idea that it may
not last forever but for now sales are
still really strong so I don't think
they're that worried yet that's Rachel
wolf from the wsj life and work team and
that's your money briefing I'm Danny
Lewis for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you